they may not be the most
vibrant but these corals are healthy and
resilient
and represent a major lifeline for the
most spectacular
ecosystem of its kind on the planet
they're part of the very first trial of
in vitro fertilization for corals
or coral ivf coral larvae
are collected during what are called
mass spawning events
their rare annual moments linked to the
cycles of the moon
then baby corals are cultivated in
floating nursery pools
before being transplanted onto damaged
areas of the reef
four years later the original population
has grown large
and even survived coral bleaching events
this proves that the larval restoration
technique
works just as we predicted and we can
grow
very large corals from tiny microscopic
larvae within just a few years
scientists say the success of this
project is critical for the great
barrier reef
the unlisted world heritage site runs
more than 2 000 kilometers
along australia's northeast coast but
it's being severely damaged by climate
change and ocean warming
it's lost more than half of its coral in
the past three decades
impacting many other species that depend
on it
at the beginning of december its status
was downgraded
to critical and deteriorating that
prompted environmental experts to call
on the australian government
to step up its efforts to protect the
reef
it's abundantly clear that climate
impacts
are real and climate impacts are
happening now
what we need is a response to this that
is immediate and significant we don't
need to be towing a line we need to be
blasting past it
and we need to be blasting past it in
leadership as well
broad policy change may take longer to
achieve
but harrison and his team say they're
optimistic their technique will work
soon these will be the world's first
transplanted coral populations to start
reproducing on their own and it's hoped
they'll start to regrow what's been lost
on the great barrier reef
alexandra byers al jazeera
well